so
um
in in some ways i haven't learned there
are certain things i haven't learned
from him and i just simply couldn't
do you mind describing your relationship
with eric weinstein when i was speaking
to eric he said that you acted as a de
facto
supervisor to him
because wow bot wasn't particularly
although it was officially his
supervisor he didn't act as the
supervisor for whatever reason it was a
strange relationship i don't understand
it i'm curious what do you think he
means when he says that you acted as the
supervisor you gave him advice or i
don't think it's correct it's more like
a coach or you know i i mean
um
so eric
uh
eric was very unbalanced
and he still is unbalanced and i don't
mean emotionally unbalanced i mean
uh he has
great talents
in certain directions
and
fear
of others
and there are certain
things that one has to do certain type
of computation a certain type of writing
basically he has fear of turning his um
his
theories too concrete
so um
[Music]
uh
and and that's
part of the reason why he had difficulty
uh
with raul balt and with um
basically with the normal system in
harvard
and
um
my role was to help him pick something
concrete out of his
big theories
and
and
and push it enough so that it became a
thesis
uh
yeah i also helped him with some
computations you know i you know
at the end of the day there are some
like so so he's come he's
you know big theories
lead to something very concrete and
specific which was a tiny part of the
big theories but we extracted that tiny
part and made it uh more concrete and at
the end it became a question you know
some big matrix 500 by 500 or whatever
it was
is it positive definite or not
and i helped him uh i helped him
decide that
and that was decided by compute by a
computer like you ended up programming
it that one that one was decided by
computer
so we just
uh but
but
but that's the kind of thing he would
have never done on on his own
because
he has this
fear of
uh
in a way it's a fear of testing your
theories
because they might fail
but in another way it's just uh
inability he never
learned how to do it he never got good
at um
turning the very abstract into concrete
um
so yes so that was my role
have you read his recent geometric unity
papers or heard about geometric unity at
all i've heard a tiny bit about it i
have not read it i'm not in the position
to comment
you talked about it's difficult to make
a concrete or take something concrete
from a theory at least in his case
do you mind giving an example of his
strengths or some are an example of a
brilliance of his that you saw
he
intimately knows
the small groups and their
representations
and how they
interact with each other
uh so
uh
the small groups like the classical
groups or what do you mean when you say
the smoke
okay what i mean by the small is um
so you know
uh
there are several families of so-called
symmetry groups
okay so there are uh
uh s s-u-n
and s-uh
and s-o-n
and s-p-n
and then there are a few sporadic ones
there is uh
uh
g2 and f4
and e6 and e7
and e8 and it doesn't go beyond eight
uh and all of these so these are
abstract things these are groups
uh
they they have so-called representation
theory
so
uh
each one of them can be represented can
be written as a group of matrices
can be realized within the world of
matrices but in many ways
so eric
uh
intimately knows
um
uh
these groups
and the representations and how they sit
inside each other for small values of n
and well for all of those sporadic ones
which are all small
and their symmetries and their so-called
outer symmetries i mean he knows all
about
uh
these things
now
this is relevant to physics
because
uh you know electro weak theory
is somehow about su 2
and
the grand unified theory so as strong
and electroweak is somehow about su 3
or
uh so
no no no no i have it wrong
sorry electromagnetism is
well
electromagnetism is you one and then
you know i i i
i actually have not thought about these
things for many many years
so i could be saying things wrong
but yeah but his strength is that he
knows these things really really really
well
uh
or one of his strengths is that he knows
these things really really really well
earlier when we were talking about
particle physics well